like kind of nervous you guys love to
bear with me first question i had was
how did you initially blow up on tick
tock i blew up on tic tac because
i was really blessed because my parents
just have like really cool stuff my
dad's like
nuts so he bought this like big water
slide from a water park and i just told
the story
of how the town didn't want to put them
up yeah that was like that got me like i
don't know 15 000 followers like
overnight like i just woke up with like
a bunch of followers
when that happened i realized that i was
good at telling stories
i just kept posting basically what
worked so then i started posting
confessions
breakup quizzes stuff with my siblings
just whatever
seemed to work at the time i went from
15 000 to 215 000 on tick tock is social
media what you want to do long term yes
so
my goal is ideally i'd like to build a
personal brand make money off of views
off of
sponsorship if that doesn't work out i'd
still like to be in video and media in
some sort so i'd like to help other
people grow online or i would like to do
video editing whatever makes sense you
want to do
music if so short term or long term i do
a lot of guitar on my lives and i sing
not a lot of people know that because i
don't post a ton of stuff on my account
but i do
love saying i love music i think i have
a ways to go
just in terms of guitar lessons vocal
training learning how to produce
at some point i would love to do music
do you have a life plan as far as life
goes
um ideally i'd like to be making money
off of music
video content and i'd like to keep going
to my church
and really just spread god's love
and god's word at some point too i'll
probably incorporate that into my
content do you have any big projects
coming up that you can share
my biggest project is i actually want to
do a another tinder bachelorette but i'd
like to host it and do it for someone
else
what are some facts people don't know
about you i don't think people realize
i'm as religious as i am
i try to go to church every sunday i do
bible studies once a week
i don't think people expect that from me
because i'm kind of goofy and like out
there
did you or your siblings want to change
your rooms at some point and were you
allowed to
yes oh my goodness we all wanted to
change our rooms
at some point except for my brother adam
he really likes his castle
never wanted to change it but my mom
said no and when i was a kid i had the
biggest
i hate pink face i just hated i hated
pink and i was so mad she made my room
pink and she said no you can deal with
it what are some of your favorite foods
sushi and pizza do you have any weird
talents i can
make farting noises with my hands
i don't know why i can like do that with
all different parts of my body does it
bother you when people
ask to see your mom and not you no i
think it's kind of funny
that i've been working for like months
to blow up on tick tock my mom does one
tic tac
she's my most viewed video but honestly
my mom's done public speaking
her whole life and it's gonna be really
fun i think to make content with my mom
i'm not mad when people want to see her
because i love seeing my mom too
do you think there's people out there
that like your content and not just your
house i am well aware
that the main reason that people follow
me is for the house
and the quizzes i do think i have a
small fan base that comes on my lives a
lot like i see a lot of the same people
do you remember the people that get in
your lives if so who most frequently
gets on your lives
josie is the one who asked me this
question she is definitely one of my
number one people
online i do remember like pictures
because i'm good with faces not so much
names do you have any hobby
i'd say a hobby people don't know as
much about is i'm really into lifting
and i really like the gym
i'm not a gym rat by any means i'm not
like jacked but i'm pretty strong would
you consider yourself to be a health nut
or do you like junk food i'd say i'm a
workout nut like i work out a lot i'm
not
super healthy i'm addicted to sugar it's
bad i love
dessert but i'm really working to get
healthier and healthier every day so
hopefully in like five to ten years i
can call myself a health nut
are you still going out with people from
your tinder bachelorette
no unfortunately i did not find love
on this season of the bachelorette i
don't think anyone really does is it
hard to stay present in life when you're
always thinking about making content yes
it is so hard because i always feel like
i'm distracted by my phone
and i probably don't work on it as much
as i should is it hard having so many
siblings there are pros and cons there
are hard things about it
but i would say overall it's been great
if you guys like this content subscribe
to my channel
follow me on instagram put a little box
right there
that has everything in it but yeah i'll
talk to you guys later
bye